okay external communications is kind of
important too yeah so here at launch we
use a couple different tools for this
one are you know four external
communications and there are different
types but one thing that I did when I
first started here was to kind of
organize where all those communications
were coming from and who they went to so
we use we utilize Zendesk and front for
this so you know when you go into our
website you'll see different email
addresses for the different events we
have going on so like you know for lunch
festival we have Festival at launch Co
and then we have all of those feeding
into a specific inbox that you know are
Toronto team can look at and jump in on
you know so getting those separated is
actually and having you know
communications go to the respective
teams is really helpful and so obviously
you're organizing all this incoming
communications and then the sales team
obviously has got a lot going on how do
we manage the sales team and the
marketing yeah our sales team uses a
combination of pipe drive and mix max so
we keep track of all of our deals and
pipe drive all you know of course which
feeds into slack and then we have a tool
called mix max which we use for
prospecting and qualifying mix max is
really cool because you can create
canned responses and the there are a lot
of really cool enhancements you can make
to your email so like for example
instead of directing people to a
separate calendar link mix max has that
built into the email so all the person
has to do is just click on one of the
options and the meeting schedule it's
really a mix max outreach there's a
bunch of these different tools some
people use Salesforce all of them work
slightly differently but to do the same
thing manage the flow of leads and do
email sequencing to you know sort of
automate part of the process okay yeah
and then the third recommendation I
would make would be to publish
documentation so we have you know
frequently asked questions on our site
when you see your support team answering
the same questions over and over and
over again you really need to get those
published somewhere yeah I know Zendesk
has Zendesk guide and you can use that
to create public knowledge bases and
then also you can create an online
community so that your users are
actually communicating with themselves
and they and your team can actually step
out of it in some case yeah you see that
a lot with Apple Apple has LEM who's
message boards every time I have a
problem with something with my iPhone or
when I do a search it sends me to like
mess
boards and the Apple people are not
super involved and then like the Apple
customers are like oh yeah this is a
known problem like the iPad pro keyboard
is just garbage it's broken I returned
mine three times just go into the store
and tell them it's never worked and
they'll do it now it's like okay so I
want to the sir I was like it's never
worked like we'll give you a new one
it's like oh wow great yeah and also for
our accelerator it's always like the
same 30 question so what I do now is I
have a snippet of text that I've got in
my browser so I can instantly publish
that just tells people like here's a
list of frequently asked questions
here's I used super-human where
investors in that company and I can do a
very quick ctrl shift I to do an
introduction or reply to an introduction
and then I can paste my standard snippet
of hey here's Jason Dumont who's the
managing director of the accelerator you
can visit our frequently asked questions
and discuss with him blah blah blah blah
blah about the next class and then he's
got his own snippet that he hits and
replies back to them and so we just
start every conversation on second or
third base you're just 50% of the way
through the process 60% of the way
through the process and it's a big part
of I think also speaking with some
consistency that's why I love snippets
and people really writing concise
answers to the repeatable questions no
we don't do that we don't have that
feature we don't you you know our
software doesn't do that or yes we're
adding that feature and here's when you
can expect it okay great